why is it only that in certain models of
the Multiverse that you get changes to
the laws of physics why wouldn't there
be modifications to the laws of
mathematics we just assume that
constants are finally tuned or matched
to the specific physics that we observe
and it's not even clear that measuring
the bods s to disappoint you but that
wouldn't necessarily prove that the
Multiverse exists either we're in a
Petri dish and there could be other
petri dishes and there could be other
colonies within our own petri dish but
the chemical speed of communication
between those colonies is so slow that
we would never find out about them but
we know that there's this agar gel that
we're sitting on top of so that at least
the potential for other bacteriological
cultures exist and so that tortured
analogy is the only way I can think that
discovering inflation means the
Multiverse is motivated but again it
wouldn't be proof